[Music]
take me to your leader
oh wait I am your leader waiter are you
a robot or Martian I'm actually your
boss Michael Scott welcome wow you are
very exotic looking was your dad a GI or
totally inappropriate that's access
rashida Jones along with Steve Carell in
the long-running comedy The Office she's
played versatile characters in movies
and TVs including Parks and Recreation I
Love You Man and the social network now
she's playing detective Angie Tribeca
it's very funny this is teracle police
procedural comedy of the same name Angie
Tribeca
Steve Carell and his wife are executive
producers in the season 3 premiere
Tribeca returns to work after brief
retirement as a stay-at-home mom welcome
back right back and not a moment too
soon
I'm afraid the unthinkable happened a
rich white man's disappeared Duncan
Farnsworth III disappeared from his
helicopter two days ago I'm pretty sure
it's the third sir already seeing a
pattern how do we get along without you
what do we know about this guy other
than his dad and grandfather's first
name married three kids got rich
inventing an oil that doesn't wash off
penguins got it guys rashida Jones
welcome back to the table I said it's
like stupid smart silly smart Steve
Carell says this absurd and very very
funny with lines like there's a couple
on a date he says I want to hear more
about that but first tell me about your
mom's mammogram you go what did you say
so when Steve Carrell approached you
What did he say this show was gonna be
about he sent me an email and his wife
Nancy and they and he said this is
probably the dumbest thing you'll ever
read and we hope you like it as much as
we do it was he was right I did I liked
it so much this is my favorite type of
comedy because oh wait why did you like
it I think well airplane is my absolute
yes love it holds up it's so funny
there's like ten jokes per minute it's
totally absurd everybody's playing it
completely straight there's something
about the tension of
playing it so straight and having the
most ridiculous things happening around
you that I just find so satisfy and you
are Angie Tribeca we should say she's a
police officer yeah yeah I would assume
you look at the writing because your
writer yourself yeah no I mean listen
I'm very lucky I'm surrounded by great
writers our showrunner is an amazing
writer and you know I I don't have to
focus on that but yes the writing is
number one for me always but Angie
Tribeca doesn't crack a smile yeah yeah
no I'm dead serious yeah how do you do
that we were under and I were talking
about that this point how do you do that
it's a little far so goofy it's so goofy
we had a scene the other day where Hayes
who plays my partner were fighting in
the car and there's a full like car wash
with like guys and speedos rubbing
themselves so subs like soap and suds
and we're like having a serious
conversation and I found it really
difficult to keep a straight face I was
doing ruinous Dave girl says that you
were the linchpin for this show that's
what he says what was your impression of
him when you first met him I mean he's
one of the most talented people I've
ever worked with
he's virtuosic every single tape it's a
nice ceremony down virtuosic yeah he
really is he's just such a he's an
athlete you know and he every single
take was like this brilliant weird thing
that you didn't expect from him you know
all the stuff you don't see on the
office and he's such a nice person he's
a much better real boss than a fake boss
how much protection I'd like to get from
your father a lot your dad was Quincy
Jones my dad was Quincy Jones and he's
what is he say I would like to see
advise Quincy gives you because he has
lived many many lives has had many life
experiences his advice is really always
about the heart because for him I mean
the thing that he did so well is he
pursued something that he loves and
that's why he did so well you know he
works really hard and he loves what he
does and he's always he always tells me
to follow my heart I know he's got a ton
of friends in every business he does he
does and he keeps going like you never
and your mom is Peggy Lipton yeah yeah
now is it true that Angie Tribeca shoots
at the same place where Peggy Lipton did
Mod Squad yes that's true that same
not the same studio but what about next
door last season we shot in paramount at
the at the lot next to where she shot
Mott squanchy it sounds that a Rashida
say it's the same place okay it's the
exact same place better the next door
she came to visit me and it had been 48
years since she had been there she's so
crazy there's a little plaque on the on
the wall this is but you went to Harvard
you went to Harvard back in the day and
even when you were student did you think
I want to do this business no idea
pression Quincy wanted you to be in this
business no I don't think that did no he
did he I think he succumbed eventually
because because I made him but no I
wanted to maybe go to graduate school
law school maybe be a lawyer this was
not the plan but it worked out okay you
made the right decision
yeah I was gonna say being a lawyer
Angie Tribeca all the other great things
you've done
how many series has this been renewed
for this is the third season so
hopefully we keep going cuz there's no
you know dearth of so Amy what role does
deeply I don't mean a character but in
terms of being them not not a character
yet but yes no I hope I don't know I'm
not teasing anything I'm just hoping I'm
wishful thinking but you do have guest
stars coming in we have incredible guest
stars yeah I like now Natalie Portman at
hounds so what role does he play catch
he is you know Nancy and Steve are
creators they're cheerleaders they pitch
jokes on set they you know play
characters and the read-throughs they're
just they basically just shape the show
you know make fun Russia think yeah
we're great in it thanks great anything
a lot of great to have you here and meet
you thank you so nice to be here
season three of Angie Tribeca premieres
April 10th on TBS